I'm speaking to mr.
George happened and who worked on the
sydney harbour bridge as an ironworker and
i'm going to ask him what job he actually
did do you member those times. Mr everton
my job was in the roof and squad and i
reverence got consist of the three men
sometimes for there was the man
that took the river. A man that
my position was the older up for the
boilermaker i used it except the rivets and
the ready for me and i used to put them in
and the river to the other side round of
them off. And so forth. In the end which
case that we needed was meant to pass the
river for you to get an awkward look at
positions and we had over mount up after it
was to the other times we had
to put them down a sort of
a chute and they come in to
a kerosene tin the end of the chute and i
think you know take them from there with
teratomas of course and put them into
the hole and they're not all my rattler
dollar on them while the revit on the other
side is to round them over and complete
the job but if those rivets
weren't the complete. Heat heated
. They don't be taken out
because they'd sweat
a bit. And once they sweated they come
loose in the hole and the time inspectors
used to come around and inspect the job.
After they killed our bet and if they were
loose at all. It'll be taken out straight
away and other times i summarise i used
to cook rivets for the on the job. But
mostly my job was holding up for the
boilermaker. And there's
a very different job we work inside
accords. And we used to straddle court like
they're all the rivet heads and they
have to try and hold ourselves in
a position to to complete the job. The
whole of the river firmly volleyball i
cannot be on the other
side and one occasion when
the first thing i went up for the the
roadway. The squad that i was working with
where a put on the job. And
there was one river. Well as
a few rivers that i couldn't reach off
the stage in the cells. I threw them on
a box to reach and when i put my shoe.
You know overhead and turn the air on it
threw me back over the stage and. And i
fell and as i fell. I grabbed the stage and
and i held on like grim death of my two
mites the cooker and the cooker rivets and
the ball and i grabbed me. I think they got
big it's more the shock that i did. But
it happened on a friday afternoon and
which came with a weekend to have
a count of course and naturally we knocked
off straightaway the ball and i got
myself and i cook and we were all
upset and you wish went home and
do you remember how long you were working
on on the bridge. Yes i was on the edge
for fourteen months and after the archery
completed. I think floyd by the new to
tell it like me on the roadway. And i think
it was only on there for about seven
right weeks before the roadway is completed
and. The bridge is ready for the
opening. Do you member the conditions inside
the chords on the arch hood idea they
were very definite and no frankly no light
at all and that i just tell you before.
Like i used to stand head to the rivets.
To try and get down to the hole rivets in
theme for these and. And.
Sort of somewhat a bit of
a stage in but mostly where to
find our own foot in sort of thing
to get hot. What to wear leather gloves
there were stop the sparks and flying off
the rivets on the scale that come off the
rivers like after you put them in their
doors when you turn the nomadic
riveter on the machine on the sparks
fly and erupt and burn something neck and
arms and that sort of thing where to wear
these leather gloves. And what was there
were when it's hot in the afternoon and
cold in the morning or well inside the
craws very hot. You know. On windy days
because we couldn't stay up there like
they hang on like grim death and and very
windy up there and. It is only natural
and right like that it was very hot
inside but with the working conditions
like compared to other jobs. Well i was
quite happy cause those about old times
and gotten. Much work around of the time
but. I was quite happy. Do you remember
that what you do lunch time did you go
down. Oh yes we went down off the
bridge and here lunch and. Mostly we
used to come up on the cage of the punt
used to take the men up onto the bridge or
some of these to go up the cords ourselves
that. Mattie were to advocate and in the
box in the box. Do you remember.
As far as the. What did you have any
toilet facilities up on the arch.
. No not really no no we have come
down more or less to use the toilets
but because we had
a make shift sort of thing
but mostly they come down.
Tell me about the time when you worked on
the ash well to after you finished on the
on the arch. Well i think that was
a harder work than what i
was on the bridge. Out of
a load the new show till we used to have
these fifty six pound rams who to ram the
field into the into the metal grooves like
on the arch there for the roadway care
in the roadway and covered
in blisters and hands
a very sore after that was very
hard work. How many were you in
a gang of asphalt as well about four or
five of you to line up behind each other
and we'd like just follow one another through
with these. With these machines with
these rams and you know about
four or five as you say and it
was all hand. Do you remember any accidents
do you what are you working on the
bridge. Oh years so i was working just
close to a man came out and he was
a he was a boilermaker and he have
a balance and fell from the bridge and
who we were came down with to get on his
body like when he fell from the bridge we
came down of the punt there and neither
one of four men that died in
a try and rescue him. We knew his body
was there but we just had a you know
a very american. If we could have got him
but we didn't we all went home then. And
. Over it got his body about three hours
ten minutes after that the water hit the
water about ten o'clock and driver has
got his body at it. 1:10. Also remember
another man named kelly who fell he was
rather fortunate he came down feet first.
He was he was
a diver and i dived in squatted below mine
and the swimmers got there and they had
the right to take it right. Himself and
came down feet first which he was very
lucky he had to get a result of
a couple of broken ribs i think if i can
remember rightly. Remember any others
accidents and people who didn't die. Not
really. I can remember one occasion where
i was chappy sitting on the wharf there
doing these feet in the water there and
from a high fly that we could
see deep down in the water like
a through the shark cruising around near
the water and i was trying to get just man
so i do given the office that they check
of around there. And they thought either
way want or any way back but i think even
chile got out the water but i don't know
what they saw the shark or not but the
shackle truth and what we knew what he was.
By and his feet were there any other incidents
like that where were you see things
from up the top that you can remember.
Well yes we saw porters there one day
because we could see them from the
ground. We used to see them from
a height up to my own forces not only girls
and they go through lee that. You see
the boats very birds going from
underneath and that's about all i think
. How did you get to work. Where did you
live then. Well live the punchbowl here to
come down by train to the key is like the
row at least and the underground wasn't
there then and to go across the
ferry boat to the punt and
get on the part and govern the in the
box and the punt. Do you remember what
used to do in your lunch oh well i think
most of you play your field in the time
you know on
a rainy day we used to like knock off
work and we can set them play kashrut why
throw the weather cleared if the weather
didn't play well we went home to get paid
any time when it was running well i can't
remember now i want to go thirty years
a long while i can't remember
whether we were paid for
a lost time or not. Several people had
said that you've got one hour's waiting in
the company's time and one hour waiting in
your time and then after that you got so
noon. It could be right to
a long while now. I don't really remember
but i wouldn't swear to that but they
could be right. Did you get hurt at all.
Well the well the bridge was going on now
. I didn't get hurt but by
a father was worked on the beast to air
attacks and he was in the miter court in
a hospital over north sydney for it for
a while he heard he said on
the. On the girder there
and he's in there for
a few weeks he's not alive now
how did he hurt himself. Well
he's getting down underneath the underneath
the good and he came out too quick and
he said caught the top of the
girl and still is right over. And
do you remember any union activity on the
bridge. No i don't think we had much
trouble as far as unions of
concerned. Quite quite happy. You
know i get in
a unionist evie's i can't remember now.
Anyway has. What you know you in on the
ironworkers union. And we had no travel
drama the name of the secretary or the
delegates on the job. Cooksey
was i think me and i
cooksey i think was our delegate there. I
can't. I don't know the secretary was at
the time i don't know whether laurie short
or not i. I don't think it was and i
mean i don't cooksey i think she was i
mean. But our delegate there. Yes i heard
his name mentioned as
a delegate before i believe the secretary
was colin tannock but i'm not quite sure
. Content can. Colin tell it could be he
was there after i left the bridge and i
looked about and cannoli was still the
secretary then. Do you remember any amusing
instance that might have happened by while
you were on the bridge. Now i don't
think you know him years and no sir i
don't countryman in the remember any
skylarking
a thing. No skylarking now we're all very
careful its allies were always in danger
. We never took an interest skylarking these
things like that. Not on the arch low
in the workshop they use a skylark
a bit. Well i never worked in
a workshop i wouldn't know as i wouldn't.
How did you get when did you get laid off
. Well i was almost the completion
of the bridge and therefore like our
cells weren't required and i have
a reference from the doorman longs. And
it's something about treasure and. And
fifty years
a long while and i can't think of anything
else that i can really tell you about
here. Looking back at the time we worked
either bridge and the way it is now what
do you think of the proposal
to add lanes to the reg.
. Well i don't know as i think it might
spoil the look of the bridge of the harbour
bridge. Is something that we're always
treasured i try to improve and anyway. I
don't think they are done they can be
done. I think they could find some
alternatives other than build the. The
other. Span. They're talking about. I don't
think they would make the base look any
better. Do you remember any of the of the
chiefs of doormen along with the public
works do you remember what their names were
and who they were did you have any dealings
with them. Yes. And he was the year he
was the head man and i believe the man
assigned my reference to by the way he was
the. Engineers of so i like the chief
engineer and one of the chief in today's on
the bridge. It's a man
and big tall man. He's
a reference as mr. Alf
martin bevan that's mr.
Alfred martin is it right itself
and martin yes. Remember mr.
Ennis it and i think mr.
Innes here. He's not
a man that i can remember the
name remembering well fifty years
a long island they're certainly
stretcher. Do you member ever seeing
dr bradfield around do you talk to him. No
i never spoke to him but i had seen him
on the job. There you know inspect and
different right. Like. On top there is
walking around there and. Especially when
the bridge lot. He was on top there with
a with a few other heads martin
a few more that i never spoke to bradfield.
Do you remember. Were you working on
the bridge when the arch was
locked. Yes all working on
a bridge in the night slog. I worked only
as i tell you i worked on the road by
after the bridge was locked. But i was on
the bridge on the bridge lot before the
bridge locked the bridge itself
useless why sway you know vibration
before it locked and that was i was told
over the good sign that and one of the
lockable i'd like perfect. I worked on the
north side we were ever afraid when its
weight around before out
was locked. No it was
a bit nervous when i first
arrived on the basis. After
a while you get your confidence and. Who
just like an ordinary straight walk from
there on is to run around a bit like
a little frog in that and and like
i don't think i was nervous now
i think i was the youngest man working to
break the time and only just twenty one
just turned twenty one and i don't think
anyone younger than me on the arch because
a lot of men worked in the workshop but
on the ata so i don't think it was more
than
a hundred men or. Only art and talk about
the north sydney so i don't know what about
the south side. Do you have of the names
of any of the riggers do you think the
riggers were good to know.
Yes the riggers i remember
jack williams he was one of the head regulars
there and after i left the bridge. I
went to work for bread and candles and he
happened to be one of the bosses breath
and cattle so we had
a lot in common and he was my boss at the
back and kennel than this week still
working but we rode. But near
here. And he's not alive now.
Tell me when you were laid off.
We are on the dole or did you get
a job straight away. Now i say after i
finish the bridge there are lots of for
a while but for i got a job
a broken candles and been employed on the
bridge. I don't think i had much trouble
getting
a job there. He went on the dole it all.
Oh yes i was in the relief work for quite
a while after you know after the. If
anything out of breath and get all finished
what relief work did you do well to be
truthful i went away to tegra likes and i
was on the leave work there. I was.
On the wire nettles road and also
worked and there were all
gravel pits and other odd jobs
there. Fishin that sort of thing. How
much work. Did you get per week on that
on the very little i can't remember the
exact wages. I think is only about
a thirty shillings a week as a night.
You know what thirty shillings
a week every week or did you get
a week on week off of something like
relief workers only every second the third
week i think on the relief work. We never
get much do you member how much you got
paid on the bridge. He works
at the mornings too and i got
a something morning in the brita. That was
overtime of course and i think you know
always only two or three dollars two and
three pound at the time i can't remember
the exact wages. Well that the lady who
works in the office reckoned that the
minimum was about. Was about £4. And he
went for people on the arch. Well they
could be right too. It could be
a bit for paying out of course
saturday morning like made
a bit extra set there. Sometimes all day
saturday as. Do you ever what you did as
a young fellow in your off duty times what
did you go out at the weekend where did
you go oh well i was called in. My wife.
At the time and after i finished in the
bridge were married about twelve
miles out the bridge finished and
like i'd side while i found
a bridge to get married and. By
has to use to serve the daughter
now not twelve grandchildren. So what did
you do when you went out where did you go
. What was it like around
sydney in those days like
a real sydney is. So different to what is
now we had you were afraid to go anywhere
then and i left the punchbowl and my wife
lived just down of keystrokes and. I
used to get the train of an artist to
walk ups downing street they had midnight
their tickets
a try. And no worries. But i couldn't do
it now. Where did you go dancing together
plied him and the lot of old time theres
a need to get of the pele royal and we
a lot of fun. We was the polo royal
fellow royal that was i mean of the palo
royal was that was that
where the pre-agreed
or the showground. What's called the horton
pavilion was you know yeah that's right
and. You can't remember anything else.